hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
who
um I am in New York City
um hanging out an extra day after the
10th Annual Patrice O'Neill comedy
benefit it was a smashing success
um
uh I'm hanging out for an extra day
because I'm gonna go see uh Youssef
Dave's at uh the Blue Note tonight I've
never seen a show there this guy's an
incredible drummer and he's always
playing with amazing musicians and I was
like you know what I'm always [__]
leaving or I'm always you know getting
there a day later I'm gonna stay an
extra day [__] it I've been home three
months with the family dad can spend one
more day out on the road to go see this
amazing drummer and then I'll be home
for most of uh April which will be cool
so I'm very excited
um
to be going over there I got my old man
earplugs
probably gonna swing by the cellar and
do a spot you know I drop by the stand
in the New York comedy club the other
night
um sort of been staying downtown here so
I've been doing that I visited some
friends
you know didn't quite stick with my well
I didn't stick with my first 10 days of
the month
um
I had a uh
I had coffee yesterday and today I mean
what the [__] I'm in New York what am I
not going to do that
and then uh
I smoked a cigar
on two different occasions with a friend
of mine so
I owe the till two days so now I have to
go until April 12th it's just how it
works whatever it'll still be the same
amount of days but anyway
um
just had an amazing time
being out here
and uh
[__] psyched I did my laundry there's
nothing better than FD but you're on the
road for like a week
get all that [__] dirty laundry and
underwear and socks and [__] I [__]
hate stuff in the back in the bag
so um
I just went to a laundromat and did it
[__] old school style
um
because I waited till the last day and
you can't do Wash and Fold on the same
day I think you can I'm not sure I just
wasn't sure so I said [__] it I just
went and did it
and knock that out so I have all
everything's clean going back into the
bag I got the show to see and uh and
then last night
was
um
just incredible I want to thank
everybody at the stand as always for the
incredible after party but uh
see if I can remember the whole freaking
night
um
the the lineup was let's see
cyphus started out DJing Rich Voss of
course
um Shane Gillis opened [__] smashed
Eleanor
um Kerrigan went next she [__] killed
it
um I'm gonna [__] this up my old man
brain then it was uh Mo amark went up he
destroyed that's three then I want to
say Keith Robinson
Jim Norton
and then
David tell Dropped In
Andrew Dice Clay Dropped In
and Ricky Velez went on after that
if you can believe that [__]
destroyed
and then uh Jon Stewart dropped by
he [__] destroyed and then I went up
I think that that was the night and
everybody
in their own way in their own style
killed oh Cypher went up too Cypher did
five minutes
um I was [__] hilarious so I'm
sitting there going like wait cypher's
DJing out of [__] is he gonna
and VOS introsum so cyphus playing music
for him to walk on and rich is supposed
to go back to his turntables and shut it
off and all I'm thinking is as I'm
watching it I'm like there's no way Rich
isn't going to [__] this up
so you know he's playing some sort of
you know
H to the Izzo or
that there's some Jay-Z [__] so Cipher
walks up to the mic [__] dumbass Rich
boss walks back to the [__]
turntables
and of course rich is pushing buttons
and the [__] music is still going and
seif is just looking back like what the
[__] and he keeps pushing the buttons
and the music he's playing and then
cypher's fine like it's the big silver
button you know Voss is like almost
[__] 90. he can't see it
and he just starts Cypher just starts
[__] on him and he crowds laugh and
he finally gets the [__] music off
um
when they brought Keith Robinson out
uh you know Keith has had two strokes
and he has the cane and it takes him a
second to get there so Cipher was
playing Walk This Way by Aerosmith and
when that ended
on my suggestion he then played the
Jeopardy
and the crowd is looking like what the
[__] are they doing and we were just all
laughing I told him to play him off to
the the [__] Hulk music you know the
end if you're old
you know when David Banner would have to
leave another town because he got angry
and green and beat the [__] out of
everybody you need to have to go
hitchhike away and they used to play
this sad [__]
piano music
but I don't know Rich was talking so he
didn't get a chance to do that
so Norton went up
and did like [__] eight minutes on
the queen dying that had me [__]
rolling
and then uh then dice went out that's
right dice went out before a tell dice
goes out and it's like this is the
legend this is the [__] King crowd
[__] loses it
he [__] goes out there the leather
vest on the Brooklyn [__]
you know tank top it's [__] Dice and
he goes out there
does not hold back
just [__] is full on
[__] Dyson all I'm thinking is ice
[__] saw this guy
you know I saw him in 89 at the
Worcester Centrum and I'm now sharing a
stage with this [__] Legend
and just it was a man and he had this
brilliant bit uh I'm not I can't say
what it was about because it gives away
the bit was absolutely [__] brilliant
it's leading you all the way to the left
and you think it's this way and then bam
it comes back to the right uh to a big
[__] laugh he was amazing amazing and
then Dave Attell goes out and it just is
[__] David tell another king you know
he goes out he [__] kills and
um
uh wait Mo went on when the [__] did he
go on he went on no mo went on before
Keith that's right
he came straight from a writer's room
there's not much people love Patrice he
came straight from a writer's room
you know
David tell and and uh
dice just dropped in uh and then Ricky
Velez had to follow them he walked out
there like it was nothing absolutely
killed I already respected him you know
I worked with him on King of Staten
Island and uh we did a stand-up show for
Pete Davidson
firefighter thing in Staten Island and I
remember seeing him that night I was
like man he's [__] good and he's
going to a whole other level and uh
and then what happened and then Jon
Stewart who I knew was coming down he
showed up and he went out there just
[__]
you know he went out there spitting
Flames like the passion of like a
[__] 23 year old comedian
it was funny he was the only guy who got
heckled he pissed off some woman in the
crowd was [__] hilarious
um she got you know upset about
something and the second she yelled out
the whole crowd just went ah
I was like it was such a good night now
what the [__] right
so
and um and then I had to go out in the
end I swear to God I think I wore out my
[__] shoes pacing back and forth
trying to win her wondering how I was
gonna follow all of these people so uh
fortunately for whatever reason Cipher
brought me out to this [__] that
stupid Irish music
I was a [__] leprechaun so
I started trashing him I thought he was
Latino evidently he's Filipino so it
didn't even make sense what I was saying
to him
um but nobody knew you know because most
of the crowd was white and they're like
me and they're looking at him he's kind
of tan like he must be Latino
so anyway
um
and all we did was just [__] break
each other's balls like Rich Foss
brought up Keith Robinson by saying this
next guy coming to the stage is probably
going to be our next benefit
um and then you know Jim and Rich like
give each other a dirty look they've
refused to shake hands it was [__]
great it was just a perfect mix
of patrice's friends
Comics that Patrice was you know looking
up to when he started and young Comics
that loved Patrice who influenced by him
so just when the night couldn't get any
better
we end the show do the curtain call
everybody comes walking out is dumbass
Rich Voss you can just [__] count on
him to do something stupid
comes through in the clutch where he has
Maureen Taran who puts the whole thing
together by the way
uh has her phone
and he says to the crowd
he goes because
um patrice's Mom couldn't make it
because her arthritis was acting up in
her knees so she couldn't make it this
year so he goes hey he goes we're all
going to say hello to patrice's Mom
he goes on the counter tree
he goes everybody say hi Georgine
I'm thinking Georgine like her name is
Georgia and like for half as I'm doing
the math
I'm thinking wait a second is is
Georgine the real name like you know
Bill and William and as I'm thinking
that the Crowd Goes hi Georgie and then
I just take the mic I'm like dude her
name is Georgia you [__] idiot and
the whole crowd loses it and I just
start trashing Voss for being stupid we
got a video with a whole thing I I'm I
think I'm gonna post it
if I can figure out how to do it um I'll
have Andrew do it um
crowd died laughing
and here's the greatest thing we sent
Georgia that video
of him saying her name wrong
and she died laughing she thought it was
the funniest thing ever which of course
is like you know such like a Patrice
thing or whatever and I love talking to
her
and when I do talk to her I always
because you know we all love her but
it's also you know most of us know her
name
but like when I talk to her I hear like
patrice's Cadence and I hear you know
elements of him in her of course because
it's his mom so
um she was definitely missed that she
couldn't be there but uh
the night was amazing then afterwards
the stand has always comes through
their own pocket they feed everybody
give people drinks and all of that type
of stuff and uh
I got to hang out with everybody was
hanging out you know
talking to dice and he was telling me
all these [__] amazing stories
about you know throughout his career and
all that type of stuff and uh
you know what's funny is um
Eleanor you you know came from a big
Philly family and she told me a long
time ago that she used to have to finish
one of her little brother's fights
and uh
she had one of her brothers there and
she kept calling my stupid brother the
whole night just called
she said hey can you take a picture uh
with my stupid brother's girlfriend like
like she couldn't say brother she always
said stupid and I'm dying laughing
and I say to him I go
I go are you the one she had to finish
the fights for and they both in unison
at the same time said no that was Billy
and I was like like oh my God it's
[__] true
um
so anyway
it was it was a great night it was a
great night we all [__] hung out and
uh
I left at the perfect time because I had
to do Jim and Sam this morning I was so
right just you know hang out with those
guys I had a really good time as you can
tell I'm also tired because I'm [__]
old
um
you know and with that
you know another year goes by
um
I've been walking around New York trying
to get exercise that way uh
you know I brought these stupid ass
[__] boots with me because stupid
club soda Kenny told me it was he scared
the [__] out of me he sent me this text
before I went to Ottawa and he told me
like it was like [__] you know
I don't know I'm an idiot I read it like
it was it was freezing out and it was
going to be snowing out so I got these
giant stupid
boots that I bought
when I did a gig in Iceland and they're
[__] amazing boots when it's freezing
cold out and it's wet out because they
keep your feet dry but it's been like
balmy the this entire trip I mean it
snowed a couple times up in Canada but
it was really close
to almost being rain and I've just been
walking around with those dumb shoes for
the last three [__] days in New York
like they're good shoes if you're
walking up a mountain not walking along
[__] asphalt and they're hot they
make your feet hot as [__] unless it's
like you know 20 degrees or lower
evidently so
um
aside from seeing my lovely wife and
kids I'm really looking forward to
getting home so I can take these goddamn
boots off because I can't fit them in my
[__]
carry on
oh and they got this stupid metal things
around the uh the laces so they always
set off the alarm at the uh
at the [__] airport so I got to take
them out it's a whole it's a whole scene
and then also when you [__] time up
you know the top three uh
lace things don't have a hole they just
have like a hook
you know and just inevitably it comes
undone like a bow tie and just all
you're doing is just the whole it's good
for your hammies every day all you do is
bend it over and re-tying your [__]
shoes
um
maybe that's how all that's all how all
those [__] people die on Mount
Everest you know they go up with those
boots
you know they keep coming undone they
gotta have a better system than that
um
[__] nuts is it that people still do
that
climb out like how boring a person are
you
that you have to do that so you have a
[__] story
you know what I mean it's like those
idiots that like film themselves they
climb up like a cell phone tower and
they're hanging off of it
it's like or you could learn how to tell
a story
you could learn how to approach a woman
and say hello like why do you have to
like risk your [__] life
um I do find it amazing Mount Everest
that they just like yeah we're not
getting those bodies
you know I sometimes feel like that with
like
like the Coast Guard
when there's like some crazy storm
coming and they warn every [__] jerk
off with the boat this is a big one but
telling you don't [__] go out there
and there's always some [__] [__]
weekend warrior dumb [__] it's
got to take his stupid ass [__]
20-footer out there with a couple of
dumb broads whatever the [__] he's doing
you know try to get his kilo of cocaine
for [__]
San Diego up to [__] San Francisco
whatever the [__] I always feel like
there's just a bunch of illegal activity
going on out at sea
you know
and what do they do they go out there
and they get themselves in trouble and
then these poor bastards the men and
women of this the [__] Coast Guard
gotta go out there you ever see that
[__] when these idiots get [__]
washed overboard
you know and then they [__] like
these guys
fly out and help with in helicopters in
that [__] weather with the goddamn
wipers on like that helps right going
out there and somebody will literally
jump out of the helicopter into the
[__] water
look at they're not all [__] idiots
some of them just get caught and [__]
but I'm just saying like
I just I just feel like
you know if I was in the Coast Guard
I think the number one thing that I
would be suggesting in meetings it's
like hey you ever see those bodies that
they just sort of leave up on Mount
Everest you know I think every once in a
while maybe we should do that
like
you know we [__] look I get it if if
some [__] happens unexpected [__] but
when they tell you not to [__] go out
there and you go out there anyway
you know
uh you still got to go get them I mean I
I took to this [__] day
what would you rather do I mean
personally I mean I I 100 will choose a
land death over and out at sea death
any [__] day of the year
I mean the [__] emptiness and the
loneliness of just being out there
floating by yourself you might as well
be on another planet it's just like
and then just sitting there hoping that
hypothermia is going to take you
because you're only other two options
are drowning or getting [__] eaten by
a goddamn shark
by the way why don't killer whales
kill people
you know what I mean
you know it's [__] up maybe if they
went around and they killed more people
they wouldn't stop getting hired at
[__] Sea World you ever think of that
like no one ever tries to [__] like
water ski behind a shark
or have you know try to make a great
white shark just like [__]
you know those dolphin tricks
why that's a really weird thing are
sharks just they don't have as big a
brain it's funny they're not as smart
but they're smart enough not to have to
do tricks at SeaWorld
it's kind of like the difference between
men and women oh my God am I doing like
[__] 80s stand up right now I think I
am
you know
like sharks are just dumb enough
to not be smart enough to have to do
tricks at Sea World that's kind of like
a guy
you know we're just dumb enough to be
able to sit there with a [__]
sandwich in a game on and understand
that like
this is [__] great right where a
woman is more complex
evidently has a bigger brain like a
dolphin
or a [__] killer whale and then how
do you equate them they don't jump
through hoops
what's the difference between that is is
the the land women make the guy jump
through the hoop so I guess we're dumber
than sharks I'm really in like over my
head on this one I don't know what the
[__] I'm going with this but it's kind
of funny huh
like if a killer whale comes up
people don't get scared and they don't
eat us
where a shark comes up you know [__]
dumbass shark is like what is that
that's sort of weird looking scales you
know as you're sitting there in your
[__] pants
because you got washed overboard off of
some [__] pontoon boat after the
coast guard told you not to [__] go
out there you jerk off and they got to
come up and they gotta take a bite out
of you
to see what you are to be oh all right
I don't want to [__] with that right
what can killer whales just know you're
wearing pants and that's going to get
stuck on their teeth so like I'm not
[__] deal with I don't know
there's a lot of things I don't know
people and I think I just talked about
them for a good 21 minutes what do you
think about that
um I'd say there's some advertising but
I haven't got the email yet
um because I'm trying to knock this
[__] thing out
um I did a good job this this trip as
far as like not getting other stuff like
extra [__]
a buddy of mine turned 50. one of the
guys I was like smoking a cigar with and
he gave me a stack one two three four
five
are they called Koozies you know those
things you put around a drink
I always said Koozies for [__]
[__]
they'd say oh so it keeps the drink warm
so it doesn't no I mean cold so it
doesn't warm up in your hand it's like
yeah or you could [__] drink faster
you know I just feel like these are like
like training wheels
maybe it's for people that actually know
how to drink
[Music]
um
anyway so I got
I got five of these they're light
they're small they're compact it's
almost like the size of two wallets
so that's not a bad thing
to bring back
you know people always like
that's that's sort of something people
never think of like when they go to give
you something
right
and you're you're and you travel to see
them
like just remember that they have to try
to get this in their luggage
like you don't want to give them a job
like oh my God Jesus Christ a painting
thank you
I know exactly where I'm going to put
this in my house
I mean
listen I think if somebody gives you
something that's just too big to fit in
your luggage or get on the plane
that's when you just stick it under the
bed of the hotel
you just leave it there
it's for the whoever finds it you know
what I mean you just call them uh
you know the cleaning lady gets it she
can [__] flip it on eBay or maybe you
know
re-gift it to somebody
oh no you shouldn't have I mean
seriously you should not have
how the [__] am I going to get this in
the overhead compartment but you can't
say that because then you're an [__]
because somebody gave you something it's
also a great way to [__]
sort of prank somebody
you know just give them some ridiculous
gift that they can't get on the [__]
plane
you just sort of filmed that like
[__]
look on their faces they're smiling
because they know they're supposed to
say thank you as they're doing the math
in the head like how the [__] am I going
to get this home
oh Bill shut up
um
all right well um I imagine if we have
some advertising
I'll record it later and we will insert
it here so I'm just going to announce it
like it's happening all right everybody
here's a little advertising for this
week
ah geez I'm standing out in the parking
lot here
um all right stamps.com a little time
travel here stamps.com all right when
every person moment and penny counts in
your business you can't afford to take
any of them for granted stamps.com gets
it because for the last 25 years they've
been helping businesses Like Yours save
time and money uh so you can focus on
your business knowingstamps.com has all
your postage needs covered with premium
discounts and great rates a post office
in your office with stamps.com all you
need is a computer and a printer they
even send you a free scale Jesus Branch
out your business with that uh free
scale there so you even have uh so
you'll have everything you need to get
started if you need a package pickup you
can easily schedule it through your
stamps.com dashboard and if you sell
products online stamps.com seamlessly
connects with every major Marketplace
and shopping cart running a business
isn't cheap especially when it comes to
fulfilling orders for your customers
luckily stamps.com says carrier
discounts about to 84 off all USPS and
UPS rates
plus stamps.com automatically tells you
you achievement this is like oh my God
you're overselling it we get it you're
[__] amazing for 25 years stamps.com
has been indispensable for over one
million businesses get access you
already said this [__] uh sign up with
the promo code Burr Burr for a special
offer that includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and a free digital
scale no long-term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page uh and enter the code Burr I'm
announcing the Monday Morning podcast
live that's right I'm doing a live
podcast and if you can't get to LA to be
there in person you can watch it online
Oh Billy freckles Live In the Flesh one
click over from the porn stars uh the
Monday morning podcast live tickets will
be available for all Monday morning
podcast listeners to take part in the
digital experience no matter where in
the world you call home
um this is it digital experience after
you're done banging your [__] robot
sex doll you can get up and watch me
digitally uh oh there's an aperitif uh
April 23rd at noon Pacific Standard Time
3 P.M Eastern Standard Time 8 P.M
British standard time or 5 a.m
Australian Eastern Standard Time
right when you're coming home from the
pub out there right from head button
some cutting the teeth whatever they do
over there tickets are 10 bucks uh at
www.moment dot Co slash Bill Burr
m-o-m-e-n-t dot co uh Slash Bill Burr
all right check it out if you can if you
can't no big deal
and there we go that was the advertising
um if there was some if there wasn't
there was like a [__] three second
four second pause in this thing uh with
that let's talk a little bit of baseball
here Tampa Bay Devil Rays sorry don't
say Tampa Bay don't say devil raise or
off to a great start your New York
Yankees are off to a great start by
Boston Red Sox with two and two uh the
last I checked
we are sort of picking up where we left
off last year where we're scoring a lot
of runs
while letting up a lot of runs so oh
[__] I got the hiccups
um
I'm hoping that we will our pitching
will come around this year
um
um I think we're back on the Chris Sale
watch I have no idea
I haven't been able to watch watch a
game yet
oh you know what these hiccups are these
are a
I wolfed down
two slices of pizza
before I did a podcast you can't do that
and then you sit down
something about that you're kind of
folding your body
um oh I didn't even talk about Donald
Trump I was in here when they they they
uh arraigned the guy whatever the [__]
they did with them
um
all right you guys know I'm not a big
politics guy but I am a [__] uh
Sports guy and I gotta tell you I think
that was the dumbest [__] move
you know I just that was so stupid why
would they do that
like this guy was like dead in the
[__] water nobody was talking about
him and they just put him on the front
page of every newspaper he has the money
to beat this
and then when he beats it I'm calling it
right now the New York Post is going to
have the cover of their paper it's going
to say the new Teflon Don because
remember they had John Gotti
uh I think there's a really
bad [__] I haven't been paying attention
but like you shouldn't
this is just going to cause
well they've already been doing it
every president has been getting
attacked since [__] Bill Clinton lied
about a [__] under oath
you know the Republicans went after him
you know not because they gave a [__]
that he [__] lied under oath about a
[__] [__] it's because he was a
Democrat douche to them right so then
what do they do then they go after
[__] George W well he didn't really
win the election and then George W's got
to [__] deal with that [__] while
he's trying to run the country and then
because the Democrats did that then the
Republicans like well Bob is not really
from this country then Obama has to deal
with that and then Trump becomes
president and everything he [__] did
they were jumping all over I just don't
I don't think and then that you know
like they're not going to go after Joe
Biden all the [__] that that guy's
done
um
yeah they're all filthy
but I don't think it helps the country
if the standing president has to
constantly [__] be fighting some sort
of legal battle I don't think that helps
anybody out and uh
I think this was a dumb move by liberals
to go after this guy
I was joking on Jim and Sam today it was
like
he was like a one-hit wonder right he
was there for one term so now he was on
like the casino circuit
singing his one hit right shoot that
poison arrow through my heart all right
and then they just they just wrote him a
hit song they got him back in the
[__] papers
um
I
I don't I don't like they're doing this
not I feel like they're doing this not
because they give a [__] that he broke
any law
I just think they're doing this because
they want him to get convicted of
something so he can't run for president
this is really not a unique thing but
like don't they understand what like
what do they think conservatives are
going to do just sit back and let them
do this like they're not gonna then go
do it like they just opened a [__]
can of worms
and um this is bad for everybody we
gotta like everybody's gotta [__]
settle the [__] down
and when you lose the White House just
be like hey man you know you win some
you lose some let's try to work with
this person
as opposed to trying to get everybody
[__] impeached the entire time
um
I know it was kind of funny they had
like as all these helicopters flying
around and they were all worried like
something was going to happen and like
nothing happened and nobody really cared
as far as I I don't I'm kind of out of
the loop but um what do you guys think I
think that was a that was not a good
move
that reminds me
of like you know
when you're in a playoff series
and you're winning
and you're gonna win a game and right at
the end of the game
your team does something stupid to rub
it in the other team's face
and they were sitting there the other
team right before you did that their
shoulders were slumped
you know
they kind of given in to the fact that
they were going to lose the series and
then you just you do something stupid
right like bite somebody's finger like
that guy in [__] Burrows on the
Vancouver Canucks
poke the bear and the Bruins wake up and
then all of a sudden we win a game seven
and we're hoisting the cup instead of
them
um you know the Bruins have done it I
remember we sprayed water at PK suban
that was not a good [__] move
um I feel like that's what the left is
doing here
um
I don't think that that was a smart move
we shall see this is like wrestling
it was like wrestling like he was down
for the cover what toe and then all of a
sudden he's get the [__] he put He
put his [__] wingtip on the bottom
rope
oh God here we go again this should be
interesting
anyway that's my dumb take on it
so it's still bugging me that guy you
[__] Centrist what a [__] [__]
um
what does that even mean you [__]
[__] who tries to listen to both
sides before he makes a decision and
doesn't just make a decision on the
color of a tie you [__] jerk off I
mean I am a jerk off like I'll take
stupid all day long
and Jesus Christ did you listen to me
talking about fish earlier
um those were dolphins or mammals
hey I mean Nature's gonna do what like
nature does
you know it's a new kind of graffiti in
New York self-help graffiti
I'm walking on the sidewalk and there's
like people like writing graffiti that's
like advice
you know don't lose your soul to sell
your shingles or something I can't
remember some sort of alliteration
just like you know all right
what are you doing [__] writing all
over the sidewalks
um all right I've overstayed my welcome
okay this is the podcast God blessed all
of you yet
go [__] yourselves have a great weekend
you [__] and I'll uh I'll talk to you
on Monday
and free Oh Canada hey what's going on
it's Bill Burr and it's the Monday
Morning podcast for Monday April 6th
2000 and uh 14. well some of you
probably wondering hey Bill you're a
you're a you're a full-blooded [__]
American
right
what do you what are you coming in with
this week's podcast singing the Canadian
national anthem Oh Canada
you know why because my stupid [__]
recorder for some reason I gotta talk
for 30 seconds for it to get the proper
the proper levels so what am I gonna do
huh you sing a national anthem is what
you do I was singing about the walls in
my house
why do people put [__] on the walls all
it does is crack the [__] Plaster
there but if you don't have pictures on
the wall people think you have bodies in
the basement
um speaking of Oh Canada how about those
Boston Bruins turning it on
when they needed to turn it on all you
[__] fans up there in Ottawa skating
down the river on your way to work
what'd you think was gonna happen did
you think that you were going to catch
the big bad Bruins huh one of the
original six how dare you Ottawa
you stand down
you stand down and you watch that River
melt you watch the water run like the
tears going down you [__] frostbitten
cheeks because you ain't making the
playoffs
playoffs the [__] playoffs the Bruins
are
and I'm calling it right now we're going
to play the Montreal Canadiens in the
first round
and we're game one we're getting our
first win against those [__] silly
sock French [__]
oh French people love their silly socks
and their little pocket squares going to
the game with their blue blazer
thinking that they know more than the
[__] coach those [__] right we're
beating them in game one
that's what we're doing what's gonna
happen in game two I don't know I didn't
think that far
but if you would like a prediction
I just heard the door slam I think my
wife just woke up she's pissed at me
already
um if you would like a prediction uh I
say that we come out there and we we win
again
yep then we go down to Boston right oh
[__] well [__] tickets and thank you
is he [__] a killer we're gonna sweep
them
we're not going to sweep them I don't
know if we're gonna [__] get out of
the first round but I can tell you right
now if we if we actually if I'm [__] it
I'll tell you right now if I'm a
Montreal Canadian fan I got to be
thinking if I'm playing the [__]
Bruins
if we lose if you guys [__] lose to
us
after the season we had after the
domination that you guys [__] at you
got you can't tell me that's not
creeping in the back of your little
French [__] brain there isn't it you
know your little wannabe French braid
you're not French you're Canadian that's
right you're part of North America
you're part of you're attached to us
this obesity it goes right up over the
[__] borders right up to you Timmy
hose with you guys sitting there eating
your [__] Donuts what do you think
you're better than us because you got
you Canadians you eat your [__]
donuts with your little pinky sticking
out huh with your loafers and you know
socks
you little [__] pocket squares huh
is that what you think I'll tell you
right now
the playoff stuff I'm gonna go total
cliche here Plato store it's a whole new
season everybody's doing so I got
nothing to lose
they're playing desperate they'll tell
you the desperate team was dangerous do
you guys watch any sports this weekend
can somebody explain to me how Wisconsin
beat Kentucky somebody explained to me
how a team playing the game of
basketball a team that is whiter than my
thighs somehow
beat the Kentucky Wildcats see that
that's why you can never be prejudiced
you can't be racist because it is always
going to prove you wrong I don't know
[__] about hoop I don't know [__] about
college basketball I don't know [__]
about a lot of things and I sat down to
watch that game and I'm looking at that
number 44 in Wisconsin I'm like this guy
is a mess look at him he looks like he's
in a jam band this guy does not look
like a [__] basketball player and all
of a sudden he's doing all this Kevin
McHale stretching around
I don't know was it was a hell of a game
and um I actually uh
I've become a Wisconsin fan just because
of uh I told you guys this uh guy
developed the show with and I went on
tour with Nate Craig who's a big
Wisconsin guy and uh so
I like those guys so I root for that
team but however
I'm also a big Kentucky fan so it was
this weird thing I didn't know I love
John Calipari
and uh hey John fork and Calipari over
there
um
yeah you know I [__] love Italians
and I love Italian food so here's this
guy and then I also like how Calipari is
a little shady you know what I mean how
did he turn that program around in
Memphis somebody explained to me how I
never even knew that Memphis even had a
school forget about a [__] basketball
team the next thing you know he brings
him to the final four maybe he didn't I
don't know I'm just repeating [__] I
heard other people say I'm just
repeating [__] I heard Bobby Knight
[__] about huh that [__] drunk with
power Maniac good Lord you ever see
anybody needs a more of a swift kick in
the ass than that guy Jesus Christ right
in his [__] khakis
laughs
um I hope when they buryth me they
buryth me face down so my critics can
kiss my ass
hey Bob whatever you want us to do
that's when he [__] went off the
rails
there were some rails and he went off on
people
um speaking of going off the rails uh I
would like to I'd like to commend a
certain Channel
out there right now that uh is not
responding to a bunch of horseshit
that's coming their way that's the exact
way you handle
this this new era of of
offended over nothing
this guy tweeted something in 1840 I
don't know about this you got to go back
six [__] years to find something bad
that somebody tweeted about
Jesus [__] Christ
you know what I mean [__] people
Jesus Christ and other comedians getting
involved what the [__] what is going on
everybody acting like a bunch of goddamn
babies [__] grow up
there you go Bill Burr speaking out
vaguely vaguely at best
um
so I didn't do [__] last night oh I know
I did last night I got absolutely
[__] hammered
um got hammered when I get drunk I call
the people I love and I leave long
rambling messages about how great I
think they are but I'm that guy
so you get mad at me because I call you
at three in the morning then you wake up
and you just laugh that was nice that
was nice he was thinking of me
um I actually I have one thing in my
office that is hanging on the wall and
uh it's a cow it's a pitbull calendar
I don't know why I forget where I got it
I think
isn't it called for the love of pitbulls
isn't that what it's called I think
that's what my calendar is called it's
great
you just look at this adorable pit bull
for a whole month right then all of a
sudden the month changes like I just
changed it this morning from from March
to April
and I literally turned the thing and I
just went no look at me no bold
and I just laughed at myself how
pathetic I am
you know even my dog right now my dog's
laying on the on the floor in his bed
it's got his back to me it's embarrassed
it's embarrassed by its [__] master
um master
[__] magic give me a [__] break
I'm not just things Master it's running
the goddamn house
um shits wherever it wants to and then I
pick it up I'm the master I don't think
so does the master walk around
huh
then again the dog is on a leash
I don't know
sounds like a bad 80s stand-up pick why
am I the monster oh [__] pick up the
[__]
that's a good [__] character huh
filthy Seinfeld
um a bad impression of Seinfeld while
being completely filthy I'll work on
that
um
why when you put your dick in a rose
don't you always scream
who are these [__]
sorry
I'll go [__] yourself you fill an hour
every week
um
anyway so the Bruins are making the
playoffs
I don't even know if they're in yet I
think they're in I have no idea
um
we got to play the capitals tonight
nobody gives a [__] so whatever so so
Wisconsin
the [__] whitest team since the
Washington generals is playing Duke
all right the Duke the Duke
um sorry they're playing Duke tonight
and I don't know [__] about either team
all I know is that Coach K always seems
to [__] win these games so what do
you think is going to happen huh do you
think these cheese eaten
yogurt making ice cream sandwich
scarfing down fat [__] of estate is
gonna go down
what are they playing
are they playing Lucas Oil if you know
it actually annoyed me that they were
that they sold it out there at Lucas
oilfield and I was thinking about uh Jim
irsay making all that [__] money
you know and it's just like what what is
he gonna do now to try to attack the
Patriots because that [__] jackass
can't beat us
[Laughter]
oh you [__] [__] he's such a [__]
you know you stole our offense
I think then you won a Super Bowl isn't
that enough for you Jimmy Jimmy
um so ridiculous it's the only owner's
name that I know him and him and old
Bobby craft
who made all that money with the cheese
didn't he which brings us back to
Wisconsin
so anyways I'm gonna watch that game
tonight and uh
and I think that's it I think that's all
I got I don't know what else I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do I gotta stop drinking
dude I've drank way too much this
[__] week you know
I have nobody you know it is I have
nobody to answer to
all right you can sit there and say that
you know you're one of these people
right I'm one of these people I just you
know everything in moderation [__] you
shut your face all right you're wearing
too much makeup first of all and shut
your face
okay
first of all the reason why you don't
drink is because you have a [__] boss
which is like having a parent all right
so I don't want to [__] hear it you
have somebody to answer to
anybody can be [__] responsible and
not drink when they have a child
when they have a boss when they have
somewhere they have to be the next day
all right
when you really find your willpower and
What You're Made Of is when you have
none of those things when you have no
children you have no boss you have
nobody to answer to your wife's cool
you know if you snore she just sends you
into the guest room right
that's when you find whether or not
you're an alcoholic or not
that's when you see if you're really
going to pass the [__] test and I'll
tell you right now whole freckles
old freckles is failing miserably
oh my God I was drinking uh
buddy of mine was [__] leaving town
so we go out we [__] drink he's got a
buddy of his and at one point the guy
comes over with like I don't know what
it was it was some sort of [__] it was
like Red Bull with a Jager shot in it
and I have to commend myself for the
everybody [__] drank it but me I was
like I'm drinking Scotch over here I'm
not [__] drinking that
Jesus Christ [__] mouthwash in a
Monster drink what the [__] is wrong
with you what are you homeless
could literally go out to the dumpster
and find something better to get drunk
off of what the [__] what if we're Red
Bull in a yate whatever the [__] it was
giving all of them [__] like why don't
you just [__] you know do a shot of
shampoo and some [__] licorice
um is that what you said bill you know I
don't really remember
really remember I just remember uh
being smart enough not to drive
I don't do Uber though I'm old school
man I get a taxi but everybody can I'll
do it I'll [__] it over your home
it's just weird to me man I don't like
just getting in a stranger's [__] car
you know without that [__] partition
there some sort of writing on the side
of the car you know a phone number
somebody can call when the guy takes out
an ax
I just I don't understand like how lazy
are serial killers that they they can't
even [__] muster up
well I guess that makes some more I
can't even muster up the [__]
wherewithal just to become an Uber
driver
why don't you make your life easier
quit [__] pulling over and dragging
people in the car why didn't you just
become an Uber driver just let him get
in the [__] car I want you to do that
is there any checks and balances on a
just [__] show up and there's a guy
hey how you doing hey person I don't
know what the
company that I I don't even know what it
is does it even exist is it in the air
is it a digital company
I don't understand any of this [__]
works
speaking of that you know what's the
dumbest [__] thing I've seen in a
while is the [__] iWatch I really
hope that that thing bombs
are you really going to sit there
watching video like you're [__] you
can't figure out what time it is and
you're just staring at your wrist is
that what you're gonna do all those
stupid features I think they're out of
ideas over there that's what happened oh
Steve Jobs died right he's not cracking
the Whip and those scientists over there
they're getting lazy what are you gonna
make next huh
earrings that you can watch YouTube
videos on it's it's over
everything that needs to be invented is
invented and that's why all these
scientists are that's the real reason
all these scientists are dying
have you seen all this [__]
yet another dead scientist
right
Alberto Behar
was a robotics expert for NASA at the
JPL
and everybody in science knows that that
stands for uh the uh
jerk plane longitude whatever the [__]
it is he died instantly
when his single engine plane nosedive
[__] scientist
goddamn scientist right nosedive shortly
after take off Friday morning from Van
Nuys airport he worked on two Mars
missions and spent years researching how
robots work in harsh environments like
volcanoes and underwater well I can tell
you they work in volcanoes they'd
[__] melt
you had to do research on that
um as part of NASA's team exploring Mars
with the Curiosity Rover
maybe that's why he killed himself he
had to keep what project are you working
on just mumbling curiosity the what
the Curiosity Rover
awkward silence at the dinner table and
then somebody with a GED starts
snickering
here we go sleep Rover let me get
because it's curious
[__] Eggheads it's the best you can
come up with Behar was responsible for a
device that detected hydrogen on the
planet's surface as the Rover moved
curiously over the surf over the surface
47 year old nasty now [__] it all that
sounds to me 47 I'm gonna be 47 in June
does that mean I'm gonna die
um 47 year old NASA scientist Alberto
Behar helped to prove
that there had once been water on Mars
according to the sad Daily Mail oh [__]
Daily Mail this is a credible Source
published to announce his recent death
in a plane crash that happened on Friday
in Los Angeles California while plane
crashes do is we're going to conspiracy
theory right here while plane crashes do
happen
and scientists do die
hard's name
has now been added to a very long list
of scientists and astronomers who've met
their untimely ends prematurely
leading leading us to ask did Behar know
something that they that they in quotes
don't want the rest of society to find
out
what the [__] could this guy is possibly
not I don't understand what people are
saying
was global warming so overwhelming to
him and he knows that the Seas were
going to rise so he just pushed the
[__] yoke forward and that was it is
that what you're saying
this guy worked on robots
they designed a device that discovered
[__] hydrogen existed on Mars
how could that hurt I I you know I
remember I used to be in a conspiracy
theory I still think that there are
conspiracies and I do think that you
know I mean I'm conspiring right now to
try to somehow do some [__] hour and
act like this is entertaining so you
guys will listen to this [__] so you'll
come out to my shows this whole [__]
thing doesn't even exist hey you are
listening to it thinking you're hearing
some sort of truth right
right there I'm gonna debunk all of
these things why did he die
um because scientists are underpaid he
didn't have uh so he couldn't afford a
twin engine so when this first one uh
the first one cut out uh you know he was
kind of uh
kind of [__]
sorry I don't know John Rogers
tropica disease expert well maybe he got
too close to the disease
and if you see the size of his glasses I
think this is why you know what these
[__] scientist problems are is they
they read too much and they ruin their
eyes and then they get then they start
flying planes and they drive cars and
they hit [__]
you know what I mean it's Gotta suck
you know what I mean as your life is
flashing before you in that Split Second
and then you know the exact way you're
gonna [__] die because you're you're
an egghead scientist so rather than me
just flying towards a tree doing the
magruber
they're actually gonna think Library
let's go to Slam against the front of
the Cradle Vortex so [__] they just they
can do all of that
wonder if they're going to be brain dead
I mean this is [__] morbid all right
Glenn Thomas
AIDS and Ebola expert Debbie why don't
you just work with poisonous snakes
while you're at it
guys sitting there juggling plagues
while he's eating a Subway sandwich no
wonder let me guess did he die of Ebola
um
and a spokesperson for the World Health
Organization well this isn't that the
trifecta this guy just shuts everybody
down at the dinner table maybe people
were sick of him dominating the
conversation
this is my husband Glenn Thomas he's an
ebola and AIDS expert and when he's not
doing that he's a spokesperson for the
World Health Organization what do you do
I tell [__] jokes in a strip mall
Ebola expert Glenn Thomas who looks
surprisingly like Chris Elliott
was among the 298 people who were killed
when a Malaysian Airlines flight
mh17 was shot down and crashed in the UK
well what the [__] yeah
he got he yeah I mean what about all the
other people that died on that but there
were some plumbers
a couple of teachers
how come everybody's paying attention to
the scientists you know what this all
this [__] comes from it's it's the fact
that everybody knows
everybody knows everybody's gone
everybody's got some Secrets right and
you know there's people up there just
the excitement they must have
you know having the cures for diseases
or whatever just the [__] that they know
like say they you know they're talking
about this giant [__] Iceberg that's
gonna melt in Antarctica that's going to
raise the entire [__] ocean eight
feet which I don't get it's like how
[__] big
this at what point is it stop being a
glacier it's just all of Antarctica is
melting
you know what I mean and I don't
understand how Antarctica right it's
just all [__] ice basically is
sitting there floating in the [__]
drink
you know if you put yeah if you put ice
cubes in your in you this is what I'm
really gonna sound dumb here if you put
ice cubes in a glass of water the water
goes up
so isn't that ice already in the [__]
water
I don't know what's going on
no bill it's on land is it is there land
underneath there I don't know what it is
I just thought it was a bunch of Frozen
water
and the reason for this is the sun is
hitting the the tops every you know what
for my whole life everybody told me the
reason why
I'll ask you guys this do you know why
it's hotter at the equator than it is at
the pulse
do you know why for my whole life
everybody said well it's because you
know it's closer to the Sun
you know because it kind of Puffs out
right
like when you had too many donuts it's
got you know Earth's got a little muffin
top
you know
it's got a lot of water weight down
there like so all of a sudden you're
whatever
you're like this club much closer to the
Sun that's actually not the case
I'm just waiting for you guys to [__]
yell at me what's basically is is
it's getting direct sunlight
and as the curvature of the earth goes
up that sunlight angle it becomes more
angled and you're not taking a it's
basically let's just put it in terms
everybody can understand
the equator is getting a facial from the
Sun
okay it's not wearing glasses either
okay it's just it's just taking it right
in the face
all right the poles are kind of looking
away and and like falling out of the way
right that's basically what it is so
it's a glancing blow they still got a
little jizz in their hair but it's a lot
easier to wash off
and that's why it's uh hotter at the
equator than it is in the North Pole you
see that everybody I'm smart
I know things not like everybody says
so anyways let's get on so how did this
how did Glenn Thomas die it is
understood he was one of them one of
more than 100 researchers who were
aboard the flight on their way to an
international AIDS conference in
Australia
oh Jesus Christ
wasn't it because there was some [__]
on the ground
who couldn't tell the difference between
an F-16 and a 747
maybe he had a quota
you know like those meter maids they
just got to start writing tickets and it
was getting towards the end of the month
he hadn't shot anything down yet and he
was just like [__] it
I don't get [__] [__] up there
moving I don't give [__] it's a [__]
drone or a goddamn parakeet I'm shooting
that [__] down and all of a sudden
they come flying over
all right
Mark Ferry
Jesus yeah grow up here yeah you [__]
fairy you had to deal with that his
whole life is poor bastard 59 years old
nuclear engineer a renowned American
engineer was found dead in his hotel
room in Salford after his heart suddenly
stopped working
isn't that mysterious isn't that weird
that somebody could have a heart attack
at 59 this is the dumbest conspiracy
ever Mark Ferry
59 from Tennessee well there you go
he's from Tennessee grew up on fried
food
Jesus Christ they barely even have books
in that state the fact that this guy
became a nuclear engineer growing up you
know we didn't have shoes right and he
just sat there he was just this [__]
anomaly
on his Cricket front porch watching his
whole [__]
family
playing instruments they made out of the
[__] junk they had in their front
yard and he's just sitting there going
I'm better than this
God damn it I'm gonna start reading and
he did
started reading like Johnny Appleseed
instead of walking he was [__]
letting his eyes walk walking all over
those books
tournament applesauce
that's what Mark Ferry did I'm going to
eulogize this guy
Mark Ferry wasn't dumb like the rest of
us in this state
that [__] I know I'm in church
I'm sorry all right I'm speaking from
the heart here okay Jesus understands
that [__] he said I'm getting
out of this state
all right I'm gonna re I'm gonna find me
a book first of all you know he had to
go to lease to Georgia
to discover he was walking the wrong
[__] way he thought I was going to
say something good about Georgia didn't
you [__] them [__] them Bulldogs right
go Vols go Vols so this [__] said wait
a minute I need to go up north that's
where they keep all the books right
because we lost one [__] war and I
got to take away all the books I get it
I get it so he walks up to Ohio
and he found himself a [__] book and
next you know he became him he became a
nuclear
nuclear engineer
I don't really know what that means and
I don't know what that does but he did
it
you're not gonna believe what the [__]
just happened my stupid recorder got
full I [__] eulogized that guy for
like another five minutes
God damn it
see it's a conspiracy they shut off your
little recording thing let me finish
this I gotta go back to this guy Mark
Ferry
so he walks up to [__] Ohio gets
himself a goddamn book and he becomes a
nuclear engineer
and as I mentioned before before the
[__] Illuminati shut off my [__]
recorder
I don't really know what a nuclear
engineer is I just know it takes a long
time to say it so that's some smart [__]
but I'll tell you this Mark Ferry
all right and I beat him up I call him a
fairy I did all that I never really even
liked the guy okay who the [__] kid
and who I'm sorry Martha I had to say it
I'm in God's house gotta tell truth
commandment number seven
uh whatever it is
[__] [__]
she she deserves that
don't see me outside anyways this Mark
Ferry
all right
despite him leaving Tennessee he never
forgot who the [__] he was
but I'll tell you right now
ain't nobody up north dies of a heart
attack at 59 that is some Southern [__]
all right you know why that is you know
why that is because I don't give a [__]
how far you leave Tennessee you ain't
leaving that diet
you ain't leaving that diet and briskets
them ham hocked and pigger sandwiches he
probably had he probably had barbecue
grease all over that lab coat
that's right man a real Southern Man the
only Southern man that makes it
to 60. if you make it to 60 is the
Southern Man I I hate you you're laying
down with another man I'm sorry
I brought me into it
well that's true
according to the Bible
um
so there you go
there you go
evidently Mark Ferry was not a fairy
because he died at 59.
I blew somebody once at a truck stop but
I didn't do it in this state so don't
make it gay anyways Mark Ferry
he's dead now and I'll tell you right
now I don't think you're ever going to
see another nuclear engineer
coming from the state you ain't gonna
see another one like that guy in a long
long [__] time
all right so everybody raise up your
jars
let's do a shot of Shine from Mark fairy
um
a Recorder's still going it is still
going so basically what you guys missed
is as I continue to read
these [__]
like any conspiracy theory it's like the
more you start reading you start
believing Professor Carol and Buster
okay she's 69 years old 69 you think ah
she had a good run she was found by her
roommate in a kitchen
all right with a knife in her neck and
she'd already been stabbed in the in the
chest
so it's just like
that's usually not what's you know
this other one had been hogtied and
burned to death it's like what are these
scientists [__] gang banging now
you know what I mean
I'm starting to believe this [__]
his one I actually believe Shane Todd
31.
PhD in electrical engineering with an
expertise with Gauss gallium nitrate
nitride
Shane Todd the man with two first names
all right here's the mystery Dr Todd
felt increasingly uncomfortable with the
work he was doing with the Chinese
company who who are we
who are we who the [__] are you know
sorry I can't I'm sorry I can't do that
maybe if I did in a bad Chinese accent
it would work
um to the point Shane told his family I
swear to God who are we
h-u-a-w-e-i
man they must be cheesy commercial
s anyways to the point Shane told his
family that he was being asked to
compromise U.S security and he feared
for his life now this guy got whacked
of course he did what the [__] are you
doing dude you're [__]
you're wearing the wrong [__] lab
coat here
Melissa
canuti
scientists have weird names she was
hogtied and burned now I'm starting to
believe this [__]
this guy 58 died of a heart attack
Zachary died of a [__] boating
accident that happens right Potomac
everybody's hammered on the [__]
platonic another heart attacks heart
attacks are dismissed here's a weird one
fan John mang
and Chung Yang Zhang that's what I got
Chung Yang Zhang
table for two for changing uh drowned in
a Branson hotel swimming pool
both were in China both were from China
and were working
dude how the [__] does two people drown
two adults drown in a [__] hotel
swimming pool
they don't even have deep ends anymore
right all you got to do is stand up
I mean I'm gonna go maybe they got drunk
it
it's like [__] two bouncy steps into
the side you got something to hang on to
ah Jesus Christ I'm starting to believe
this [__]
Gregory Stone 54 from an unknown illness
while that happens
Bradley 56 died in a car crash well you
know they're reading they don't have
good eyes
Dr massoud Ali muhammadi 50 was
assassinated January 11th when a remote
controlled bomb inside of his motorcycle
near his car was detonated I mean that
happens
an Avenue A buddy of mine the other day
the professor of nuclear physics at
Tehran University was politically active
oh yeah yeah he this guy got whacked you
should see his picture too it's like he
knows it's coming
yep got a couple more days left for this
[__]
Jack P wheeler the third 66 last seen
December 30th found dead in Delaware a
Delaware landfill yeah he got whacked
anytime you end up in a landfill fought
to get the Vietnam Memorial built and
was served and served in two Bush
administrations his death has been ruled
a homicide yeah of course it has
Christ that guy's a [__] hero that's
a terrible one this is just a
there's a horrible website you can't
stop reading it Mark A Smith 45. dude
this guy looks like he's 90. that's 45
I'm a year older than that guy
renowned Alzheimer's disease researcher
has died after being hit by a car in
Ohio
is that suspicious I don't know
I'm not even gonna try to say This
Woman's name she was dead of an apparent
suicide
by cyanide
at a Temple Terrace Hotel
she left a suicide note saying she used
cyanide
HazMat team officials said the cyanide
was found only in a granular form
meaning it was not considered dangerous
outside of the room it was founded the
chemical is considered more dangerous in
a liquid or gas form
potassium cyanide the apparent cause
potassium cyanide the apparent cause of
death is a chemically commonly used
I I don't understand what the [__] that
is
I mean she said to you cyanide is
[__] right there
another woman died in the hands of Amy
Bishop her background was in
Jesus who would have thought it so [__]
these these guys are dying like uh
Bloods and Crips here anyways let's get
to the uh enough of that [__] I don't
even know what to believe anymore I
don't even know what to say anymore
what's going on
um all right let's get to some of the uh
some of the questions here for the week
no no what am I doing I want to get to
some of the advertising there you go
let's get back to the [__] here do
you guys have a nice Easter
I had an awesome Easter
uh my mother-in-law came over right
and uh she actually wanted to go to
brunch okay
and I was just like oh I was like oh
Jesus
oh my God I thought this was a day of
Celebration why would you drag us into
the hell of brunch on [__] Easter are
you out of your mind
right this is how cool my wife is I just
say to her I said she goes do you want
to go to brunch
with me and my mother on Easter I was
like no I don't
I don't want to do that why don't we go
drinking on St Patrick's Day why don't
why don't we go out on New Year's and go
to Times Square
the [__] are we doing here she's like I
know that's right I go why don't we just
have brunch at home I'll make some eggs
I'll throw in some [__] waffles
whatever you want I'll cook it right she
goes I got one better for you why don't
we just order some [__] Chinese food
that's what we did
Chinese food on Easter
don't Jewish people eat Chinese food
on Christmas I gotta tell you I loved it
on Easter Why Stop on Christmas those
Jews I'm telling you they're on to
something
this [__] Chinese food on on
Christian holidays I'm all about it dude
it was awesome we had uh
what do we have there
we have we had uh we had I don't know
what the [__] we had crab rangu all that
deep fried [__] that's [__] sloshing
around on my belly right now is
tremendous then she showed up with a
lemon meringue pie and that was my
Easter no bunny
right no [__] going down to church
and you got to listen to the Jesus story
over and [__] over again
you know what I mean it's such an
amazing story you'd think that they
could make a good movie about it you
know what I mean I mean technically it
should be better than all of those born
identities but it isn't
I don't know what they need they should
make just you know if I look the
Catholic church is who's getting who
it's sliding down a grease Pole
you know nobody's buying nobody's going
anymore all right
it's like it did it's like the
Jacksonville Jaguars of the of [__]
religions as far as you know old stadium
nobody's showing up plenty of seats you
want to sit down front again you got it
it's all you you're right you can hang
out with the [__] players afterwards
so what I would do is I would
I would invent like the I Catholic
Church
you know
just rip off Apple to get these kids you
get flat screens in there right
you do you get Tupac whatever they did
to him where he became the the
the homogenized version what the [__] is
it the the holograph
what the hell is it begins with an H
a holograph
a little cute whatever the [__] it is
you do that but you just do it with the
priest
you have some of the best Priests of all
time the two parks the [__] Biggie
Smalls of priests and you bring them
back to life just like G but [__] it you
just bring Jesus back
that's what you do
you have him up there right he comes
down from the [__] all pixelated
coming down from the ceiling
you know what I mean
and people don't believe it's him at
first then oh what do you did you
[__] make that you shoot that with a
potato laughing my ass off on the floor
over here shaking my head that guy you
know you got to take a little [__] from
the Twitter Roxy right and then all of a
sudden you just you just keep saying no
that's actually Jesus
right and if you watch that thing on
Scientology like I did you know what I
mean what you learn other than the fact
that it just takes 2 600 lawsuits at the
same time and the IRS will cave uh
that's the only thing I learned other
than that is is that you know is that
they draw all they dress like they're in
Buck Rogers which is you know it's kind
of cool right
I'm just space movies now I don't know
what the [__] I'm saying you get some
flat screens right you get some Chinese
food
you go easy with the guilt
and you bring them back you know and you
try as hard as you can to not [__] any
more children and I I think you could
turn this business around this is like
that's what is that what is that show
where the guy comes in and he tries to
to fix your bar what's it called bar
fixer
huh
dive doctor whatever the [__] there's
some stupid name right
he comes in you're [__] bear tap
smell like my wife's vagina on July when
she gets off an elliptical all right
just
screaming at people
about their dumbass bars
you just got to do that with the
Catholic Church you just go in there
screaming why is that guy [__] a
child
right and you turn the whole [__]
thing around
what would it be it's got to be a
alliteration like Christ fixer but it's
got to be with another C cry
ER
Jesus jamming I don't know what the [__]
you call it
Christian Mingle
how bad is that Christian Mingle how
[__] creepy is mingle let's get on
here and Mingle
I really want to see your tits it just
seems like you'd just be mumbling a
bunch of [__] I don't see it says no
three-way
um sorry all right here we go let's
let's read some of the uh
let's read some of the [__] questions
here for this week shall we
well I don't give a [__] I'm running
[__] okay by the way if you'd like to
email me if you'd like to hear me read
out loud something that you wrote and
butcher it uh emails can be sent to Bill
at the mmpodcast.com if you would like
to follow us on Twitter
you can go to at
the mm podcast
all right here we go here we go all
right okay rough one here okay all right
is my husband too cheap dear bill
I'm a 34 year old [__] lady foreign
and have been married for six years
I'm hoping you can help me with some
advice on my marriage for the most part
my husband and I are pretty similar but
we have completely different outlooks on
finances
alrighty already I'm already thinking
sexist [__] here so I gotta stop all
right
I'm picturing you just buying a bunch of
dumb [__] that and you're [__] you're
driving them to an early grave but let's
see maybe maybe maybe this guy is a [__]
gonna be open-minded here all right
open mind all right my husband works
full-time and I work part-time myself
and I'm and am I
start off my husband works full-time and
I work part-time myself and am a
housewife I swear to God that's how she
wrote the sentence
should be and I am
a housewife and am a housewife you never
have [__] three short words that
begin with a in a row myself and am a
housewife and Emma
and I am a housewife
that sounds good my husband works
full-time and I work part-time myself
and I'm a housewife I get it you [__]
spoke this into a speaker right that
little magic device on your phone
um early in our marriage
we both work full-time but it became
difficult for me when I would clean the
house on days off and he would not be
helpful in sharing those duties oh this
guy's old school
lifting his feet up as you come by with
the [__] Swifter
um he would pause he would just play
video games
and I'm not a clean freak or anything I
just don't like living in a [__] show of
a house oh my God I [__] love this
woman you're right up my alley uh before
we were married he would let Dirty
Laundry pile up for weeks before he
washed it Jesus Christ This Guy's an
animal
I probably should have spoke to him
about it
spoke to him about that before we got
married or lived together first but I
did not see it as a huge issue at a time
oh you were young what did you know
anyways after a year of marriage we
decided that the best way
would be for me to do the housework and
work part-time and make dinners while he
worked full-time Jesus Christ this
[__] guy is crushing it
you know he's got an old school wife
here
listen listen you quit your dream I'll
live mine when I come home you better
have this place tidy with the [__]
steak on the table
um all right
here's the issue here is the issue with
our marriage and I would love your
opinion
this is where if I was her girlfriend
we'd be clasping both hands both of our
hands across the table this is why I
need you okay oh I'm here for you Karen
I'm here for you just just get it out
uh my husband is very
um is very conservative with our money
this guy doesn't have one redeeming
[__] thing he's a slob he's a [__]
tight Ward I hate this guy
um he will save and keep our 20 grand in
our finances for any that's smart though
I don't know he is kind of smart he will
save and keep our twenty thousand
dollars in our finances for anything
that could happen I admire it and think
it's very smart however he loses sleep
over it and we rarely will go out and do
anything together as a couple yeah his
guys he's he's taking it too far all
right
um we make enough money between the two
of us to pay our bills and save mind you
hey you don't get a [__] reprimand me
um he gives me a some amount allowance
every month to buy groceries and other
personal items
if I use another card he will confront
me and tell me not to use the other
debit card and if I am low on funds for
groceries we need to buy Ramen for the
rest of the month
all of our arguments are about money I
believe in saving money but at the same
time I think it's great to live a little
and buy items for enjoyment from time to
time I love to go out somewhere fun I'd
love to go out somewhere fun on a date
oh my god dude this is sad
with my husband without him worrying
about money the whole time I can't buy
concert tickets without asking him first
to surprise him like these guys [__]
likewise he never surprises me with
anything either if this thing ends with
you on your [__] hands and knees
scrubbing the floorboards because he
wouldn't even buy you a [__] Swifty
um what should I do I've confronted him
about how I think his fear is unhealthy
am I wrong I'm telling you
um she goes I'm telling you it's a rough
one okay I love it I love that you threw
that in there she's got a sense of humor
this I think This Woman's cool thanks I
love your comedy listen to your podcast
every week uh go [__] yourself
um
all right
yeah this This Woman's a [__] Champ
the amount of [__] she's putting up with
all right
she's got a sense of humor she's
listened to the podcast I I you know
what I I or maybe she's snowing me I
think I think I think you're totally
cool yeah this guy needs to [__] and he
needs to relax
um
I don't know what would you do here just
say look something's got to change here
all right because I haven't been to a
[__] Cheesecake Factory in like nine
years
all right you got to take me this guy
this guy you know what it is he doesn't
understand he doesn't understand women
he doesn't he doesn't he doesn't get it
you guys like to go out all right and I
think you're cool enough that you don't
what the [__] doesn't like to go out
that's such a dumb thing I just said
I you know I'm too stupid to explain it
but I totally get where you're at this
guy needs to take you out all right he
needs to remind you why you guys fell in
love
he needs to you know
just go every once in a while just say
you know what [__] it
let's go out and just blow [__] a
couple hundred bucks on a meal
right
that's it and then we just
Jesus Christ if you spend too much money
it's ramen noodles I mean this guy it's
like this this guy sounds like uh he
grew up during and during the Depression
I I'm you and you're nice enough to
admire that he thinks about [__]
money you got 20 grand saved up which is
better than most people
you could just loosen the purse strings
let a couple of nuggets fall out once
every six weeks for Christ's sake
um
what do you do there uh how do you go
about that
I know a tight wad that's a tough one
man a cheap guy is just a just a cheap
person they're just [__] cheap
that's like you're not even going to
enjoy life for Christ's sake
um
I think you got to start Roofing them I
hate to say it but you know
every once in a while the date rape drug
is uh it's called for I think you need
to [__] this is what I would do
no you can't do that so you can't do
that that's [__] I'd say I would just
[__]
give him the date rape drug
let him pass out at the table then I
would just go out and booze it up and
then I'd come home
and it'd be like and he'd just be like
did I did I fall asleep at the kitchen
table again last night yeah you did it
was weird it was like you were eating
the ramen noodles
it just
you went face down in it
I'll tell you thank God you're too cheap
to boil water and that water was at
[__] room temperature you might have
burned your face
um
I you you either got a roofie them
or as you go out are you guys or you
gotta just say listen
I need to go out
okay I can't keep living like some
[__] broad in a [__]
miserable fairy tale that's waiting for
his for for a [__] Prince Charming to
show up
all right here's the deal [__]
once a month you're taking me out
all right you're making me feel like a
[__] lady you're making me feel
attractive
all right or I'm gonna start [__]
working again
I'm sitting here watching your sweaty
balls [__] underwear and you can't
even take me to a Goddamn chunky cheese
huh you cheap [__]
I don't know how to do you know what
maybe he's listening to this dude take
her out for Christ's sake all right
listen the dollar is going to collapse
anyway see a 20 grand isn't gonna be
worth [__] so why don't you go out and
[__] buy a pork chop with it while
you still can there you go all right
here we go fear of damnation
dear Bill growing up Catholic oh Jesus
my parents instilled me instilled me
with a healthy fear of damnation like so
many others as I got older I grew away
from the church but the fear of going to
hell was never far from my mind
this is why it's funny that everybody
made fun of the [__] Scientology
movie just saying it's a cult those
people are [__] crazy as opposed to
what
the [__] we're doing
I love Scientology for the simple fact
that they sued the [__] IRS and they
went all right all right all right Jesus
Christ these people are crazy
um they beat the IRS
that goes a long [__] way
all right a couple of kids die every
year due to the common cold but other
than that I I think it's a good religion
over the course of my life
I've had many opportunities to wrong
others some were out of necessity and
some do to my own greed or poor judgment
Jesus this took a [__] left turn did
I miss a paragraph
um I lie awake at night with the details
of each sin running through my mind how
it affected those people I hurt and what
their lives would be like had I never
altered it with my own destructive
presence what the [__] did you do to
these people
this guy sounds like a worse person than
me this sins weigh on me as they should
and I wondered if I'm going to burn in
hell for the things I've done or if I
could possibly turn it all around the
Bible provides some details about the
afterlife but doesn't get too specific
about how each person is
but it doesn't get too specific about
how each person is tormented when they
reach hell
well don't ever read Dante's Inferno you
don't want to read that my biggest fear
is that after I die I would arrive and
while burning in the Eternal fire
your podcast would be playing on a loop
[Laughter]
that's [__] hilarious please help me
I'll do anything
give to charity save a puppy whatever it
takes I have to redeem myself somehow so
I won't have to hear your voice
yammering on about the NFL and cackling
at your own jokes forever
ah you got me you son of a [__] that's
[__] hilarious
um all right Icebreaker bill
I'm terrible at starting a conversation
with the girl I'm good in an actual
conversation I don't know why that guy
why don't you just not listen to the
podcast
you know what I mean maybe he listened
to one and I was so [__] annoying or
you know what's even better maybe he
works with somebody and they played in
like the warehouse
uh dude I'm sorry I know I'm annoying I
can't argue with anything you said um
Icebreaker bill
I'm terrible at starting a conversation
with the girl I'm good in an actual
conversation
what does that mean
oh okay so you can just like if someone
says uh Hey welcome to [__] Denny's
can I help you you're like yeah I'd like
pigs in a blanket dude I'm crushing
crushing that [__]
um anyways but I rarely get
anyways I'm good in actual conversation
but I rarely get there because it starts
off bad what advice can you offer do you
have any lines or topics that would work
thanks and go [__] yourself dude you're
just gonna have to learn to have a sense
of humor about yourself you're gonna
have to [__] bomb
you're just gonna have to go up and boom
there's no [__] hey baby what's your
sign line that works you got to just
come up
here's the thing
don't if you're not good at hitting on
women don't go to a [__] Meat Market
all right
what you got to do is you gotta chat him
up while you're just doing uh
jeez dude it's been so long since I've
been [__] singing I I was never good
in the meat market bars I was always
better like I met women on the train I
met him in like the [__] gym
I met him like uh like when we were
doing like we're both riding on a
[__] train you know what I mean and
there's no they don't they get they have
that guard up there I guess that you're
not going to be a Mugger what the [__]
would I do how would I talk to him on a
train I would just wait for someone if I
saw someone that I liked on a train
uh the only way I could start up a
[__] conversation is if some crazy
homeless guy
got on the [__] you know some crazy
person got on the subway and everybody's
got that old [__] and then you make eye
contact with them and then I always had
a joke about the [__] homeless guy
that's right I took the piss out of
somebody didn't have a house and that
would break the ice and then maybe you
know
you're on the subway it's like speed
dating you got to try to get the [__]
number before they get off
um
but if you if you're not good at
conversation you got it you got to get
good at it and
um I would say the gym
's kind of creepy what are you working
on you know she's [__] bent over
doing bent over rows whatever the [__]
it is uh the only advice I have here
it's just like doing stand up you just
have to get on stage and you just you
have to figure it out
um so that's what I would do I would get
over your fear of bombing by getting out
there and just bombing and have a sense
of humor about how [__] bad it's
going laugh at yourself
and just keep swinging away
just keep swinging away I don't know
just uh go go Ron Burgundy
just be like overly arrogant about
yourself how [__] awesome you are and
just say that you know that she's
thinking all this awesome [__] about you
you know if you're an average looking
guy she'll think it's [__] hilarious
and you kind of taking the piss out of
yourself there's that angle
you know what I mean I mean I don't I
don't [__] know you're not gonna ask
a married guy I have no [__] idea
anymore somebody help this guy you know
what why don't you guys why don't you
guys send me in your best
Icebreaker lines
the only one I think I ever had a good
opening [__] line was when I wanted
to hit on this woman who was I already
told you this I wanted to hit on this
woman who was with this woman who was a
redhead
and I walked up what did I say I said ah
I go oh hey another redhead I go you go
into the meeting and then a friend left
and then the redhead thought I was into
her and I had to do like you know that
swim move that Russia's do when they're
trying to get to the quarterback I had
to [__] [__] push her out of the
way and talk to the brunette and then
she was like [__] annoyed that I was
hitting on her and then her friend I
think caved to the pressure of her [__]
friend or maybe she just looked at me
like I don't want to [__] talk to you
I made her laugh though I got one last I
think I got one laugh
in all my years in those Meat Market
bars Ah that's [__] horrible [__]
horrible you know what dude I don't know
you were asking another person that
stunk at it
I can't help you so how about uh
how about uh listeners
give me your best and your worst [__]
opening lines
your best and your worst results and
I'll read those next week or whatever
and with any luck that guy who hates me
someone will be playing it in the
[__] background neighborhood bully
hey Billy bag of donuts
hey Bill I am 15 years old and I want to
know how to deal with the kid who was
bullying my six-year-old brother
well you go [__] him up step on his head
uh we live in a cul-de-sac and all the
neighborhood kids know each other they
often play at the end of the cul-de-sac
in somebody's backyard I just recently
learned that my friend's brother
sometimes brings over a friend who's
seven years old and this kid goes over
to the backyard at the end of the
cul-de-sac without the person who
brought him and starts playing with the
kids who belong to the neighborhood
Jesus Christ isn't that just called kids
playing with each other
now it's all supervised the problem is
that the kid is an [__] he calls my
brothers names calls my brother names
for no reason I know my younger brother
isn't lying based on his body language
now I need your advice
on what I should do
I told my brother to come get me so I
could come over and talk to him I was
going to be as intimidating as possible
without yelling or being threatening by
completely keeping my calm and emotional
and emotionless as he tried wait a
minute what the [__] just happened to
this sentence I was going to be as
intimidating as possible without yelling
or being threatening by keeping
completely calm and emotionless as he
tried to bust my balls
what the [__] happens with that sentence
that was in the past and in the presence
you tried to do that and then he bust
your balls I don't know what's going on
here I don't necessarily know if this is
a good idea I was looking for advice
should I tell my friend's mom so this
this little [__] can never come back
thanks and go [__] yourself P.S if you
are reading this on Friday April 3rd
it's my birthday
I'm not reading it Friday April 3rd but
happy belated birthday all right that's
that [__] email was in like 12
different time zones
so what should you do
I I don't know just walk up to him
you're 15 he's seven hey
yo
you know what's great about that age if
if you catch him off guard with a hay
they might piss themselves a little bit
you just walk up right behind him you
just go hi like that like he [__]
pees himself me so hey can I talk to you
think hey can I talk to you for a second
okay that's my little brother over there
he's telling me you keep calling him bad
names
what's what's going on with that
I mean just let him sit in the awkward
silence
and then when he tells you why he's
doing it just say look
if you keep doing that to my brother I I
don't know I I'm just I don't know what
I'm gonna do but I just keep picturing
my entire hand covering your face and
then me throwing your whole body like a
baseball over that [__] fence
you don't want me to do that
because you weigh enough where you might
land on top of the fence and that could
uh
that could poke into your innards there
do you want me to do that because I
don't want to do that all right well
then stop [__] with my brother you
little [__] that's what you do
don't do that
over to that [__] kid's awful mom
and say hey can you [__] you know
your awful [__] kid
I know you're a single parent that's why
your kid stinks all right legalism
everybody the urr
all right that is it for that mercifully
the reading out loud portion
is [__] over all right don't save
let's click over here let's let's read
the last
the last couple here
um
oh the last one 20 year old blonde
female request
all right that's already annoying
because you feel like what why why do I
need to know you're a blonde female and
how old you are
huh you're trying to get preferential
treatment Here Lady no okay Bill my
boyfriend and I absolutely love your
podcast you're our favorite comedian
yada yada yada could you ask
I'm not going to say the name in your
next podcast to marry me and I'm not
saying your name go [__] yourself love
this person P.S when are you coming to
Portland Oregon I'm going to be coming
to Portland in June
I'm putting together another little bus
run
if that will include it's going to be
Portland Oregon
uh Eugene no Eureka sorry oh sorry sorry
the people in Oregon I just [__] up
Portland Oregon Eureka California
um
Warehouse Fresno
why don't I just [__] look it up here
it's all going to tie into that Vegas
tour and then I think I we end up
somewhere in Tucson
it's going to be great it's going to be
me and Joe bartnick and I think I'm
going to get lawhead on a couple of
those [__] too it's going to be a
great time so anyways as far as me will
I ask
your boyfriend to marry you no why would
I ever do that to another man first of
all you're only 20 years old you're too
young to get married
all right and as a guy like the amount
of Guy Code I would be breaking to put
this guy in that [__] position
there's no [__] way I would ever do
that
you know what I mean and since I've been
married I've never been that person that
said to a couple that isn't married you
know when they do how many guys
we have kids when are you having kids
when you shut the [__] up that's when
we're having kids
um all right that is the podcast for
this week everybody uh
congratulations to the Wisconsin Badgers
and the Duke Blue Devils I'm hoping for
a great game tonight and uh my
condolences to the fans of uh Kentucky
and uh Michigan State
um I watch both of those games you know
me I'm a [__] I Love College hoop but
I'm a fair weather fan man I watch a lot
of hockey and then this time of year I
always jump in and I jump in
um
I just watched the final four games and
I watched the the final that's all I do
so I don't know what to tell you all
right
I'm a bandwagon guy
I am showing up with a brand new final
four [__] hat tonight I'm kidding I'm
gonna watch it over a buddy of my house
is actually a uh a Duke Blue Devil fan
so I don't know who I want to win this
one
I like Coach K winning another one just
so he can become more of a legend but uh
I'm trying hey let me look this up
when's the last time Wisconsin won a
[__] championship
Wisconsin
how do you spell it Wisconsin how do you
smell it Wisconsin stop eating [__]
cheese
uh best last basketball when I put the
[__] microphone down so I can type
faster last basketball
you guys can get on with your day at
this point this is just for me
championship
there's some fat guy
driving a Chevy LUV somewhere in [__]
Rhinelander right now with a big red
jacket on screaming
um college basketball Badgers men's
basketball all right here we go here it
is every Wikipedia
we're gonna go on Wikipedia I'm gonna
guess that they won it in the 1950s
let me see let me see let me see all
right what do you got here
NCAA tournament champions they won a
they made it to the final four in 1941
2000 2014 and 2015.
they're crushing it this century
the elite eight
41-47
2000 2005. oh Jesus Christ I
Jesus Christ
they haven't won it since [__] Hitler
was still alive the last time these guys
won I got a root for them I got a root
for The Underdogs
all right so I'm gonna root for the
badges tonight uh although I like both
teams I don't give a [__] I have weird
Allegiance you know I'm one of those
people I like Ohio State and Michigan
all at the same time because you know
I'm not from either State I don't give a
[__] I just want to see a good game and
I'm really happy that um
that that [__] uh guy with Bill
Clinton hips is now coaching [__] um
Michigan [__] his name
Captain come back there
John Wesley Harding I can't remember
anybody's name
his brother coaches the Ravens and
thinks there's not enough air in the
balls and that's why he [__] loses
Jim fassel
I don't [__] it Jerry tarkanian I have
no idea all right that's the podcast for
this week uh thank you everybody for
listening uh this week oh freckles is
coming to Florida Florida is not part of
the South don't ever forget that
Florida's Florida Texas is Texas the
south is the South I am going to be
um
uh April 10th I'm doing two shows at the
Fillmore in uh Miami Beach and I'm doing
two shows April 11th at Ruth Eckard Hall
in Tampa
uh
uh and there you go and then I come back
for a couple days and then the uh the
Bible Belt tour starts kicking it off
can't [__] wait
oh this is going to be a fun month April
18th Savannah Georgia
right
Savannah Georgia 19th we go up to Johnny
Knoxville Tennessee April 20th
Chattanooga Tennessee April 21st Memphis
Tennessee right April 22nd Shreveport
Louisiana April 23rd New Orleans we hang
there for a couple of days get shitty
get sideways we get back on the bus
April 26th Huntsville Alabama
[__] are you looking at then we drive
back April 27th to Jackson Mississippi
April 28th we go to Mobile Alabama get
the [__] out of here I didn't know I was
going there
holy [__]
um
the [__] song is that I don't know what
the hell it is
um
who's that [__] guy if you wanna you
know something I I actually feel bad for
that guy that doesn't like that I laugh
at my jokes because there's that rapper
who laughs at his [__] and he drives me
up the [__] wall too
who's that guy where he's like and I
agree
that [__] idiot he does that but I'm
still looking at him titties
it's like okay dude look at her titties
like I don't know what you're snickering
about Mobile Alabama man they built all
those [__] ships in World War II
I learned that watching that Ken Burns
documentary
wow Mobile Alabama that's [__]
legendary
then we're driving up to Lexington
Kentucky
oh my God this is going to be the
sickest [__] tour ever and then we go
to Evansville Indiana and then May 2nd
we go to the Kentucky Derby all right go
[__] yourselves come on it's tremendous
um so anyways that is the uh the podcast
and uh you know what I'll do a little uh
I'll do a little preview here
a little preview of my other tour in
June you guys don't listen to the
podcast it's over man you just listen to
me [__]
talking to myself in my apartment at
this point
um
all right none of these are confirmed
except for the Vegas date all right but
Rumor Has It
all right I heard a room that that bill
is going to be in Portland Oregon
uh gonna be in uh Eureka California I
got a Reno date possibly Santa Rosa San
Jose Fresno Bakersfield Highland
and uh then I'm definitely doing two
nights in uh Vegas at the Mirage casino
and then Tucson Arizona
this is this is the idea
that we're trying to put this [__]
thing together and uh I go on there with
Joe bartnick and then he's gonna have to
jump off the bus to go do a couple dates
with Versi and then uh I'm gonna get
lawhead on a couple of those that's that
is the that is the game plan as this
comes together
um so anyways I'm babbling here